before i play this
i'm going to be completely honest with
you i had no idea who any of these
chicks were and it wasn't until i
started watching it when she was talking
about
her past and how some guys would shy
away from her because of her past and i
was like okay well what is she talking
about what does she do in her past
and she started talking about dropping
out of school in grade eight
joining a cult or what seemed to sound
like a cult going to jail
and working in porn so it turns out lana
rhodes is a porn star
um news to me maybe not news to some of
you guys
uh apparently a popular one too she's
got well over a hundred scenes from what
i could tell when i googled her name
um ladies got a big notch count i can
tell you that and she's sitting here
lecturing on what trophy wife training
looks like with her two other friends so
let me throw these in here
and we'll get this ready here
okay all right so
i got it cued up here um i got a few
notes so
before i start playing this because this
is her summary of
all of their points um
she talks about tumblr and what trophy
or wife training looks like from the
perspective of hypergamy
she completely butchers what hypergamy
is
on the sexual marketplace but she
basically distills it down to
uh gold digging and women seeking men
that are of higher education
and of greater wealth which is somewhat
true but
she misses you know many of the finer
points which is to be understood you
know the
women go on uh their social apps and the
tumblers of the world and
they'll go and learn a new term
hypergamy and they'll go talk about it
and there are three girls in a kitchen
cast and try to educate ladies on
uh why that ties in a trophy wife
training but anyway
she goes on to talk about uh sexual
partners
and how a friend of hers got dumped uh
because this dude found out about her
sexual past
and you know she goes on to talk to
ladies how sexual passion matter
uh women will lie to other women about
the irrelevance of their sexual past and
i'm going to share some
data that i have so from some men here
on two different
surveys that i did in the last two weeks
i figured at some point i had to cover
this topic so it segues in nicely that
she's got her trophy wife training video
and i've got my data on what men really
like
so i'm gonna cover her stuff first right
now and then we'll get to what guys like
and we'll do some q a call-ins today
as well uh blah blah what does she
ramble on about here my notes ramble's
on about style making a high value women
again i'm not going to play all this
because
you guys can go and search the castle
watch all if you want because it just
causes problems with youtube but
she rambles on about how style makes a
high value women truthfully
most guys don't care that much about
style i mean as long as she's
fit not overweight and she knows how to
put on
you know a decent outfit it doesn't look
like a slob
i mean you'll find most guys are happy
with even a woman in some form-fitting
yoga pants to be honest with you
she rambles on then for even longer
about fake lashes and how that's
important for high value
women she rambles on about perfumes
which i personally can't stand women
that just like
drink perfume because they just reek of
it hurts your nose hurts your eyes
a light dusting is fine but she puts a
lot of emphasis on fake lashes perfumes
style oh they also talk throughout this
cast
about um this term bad [ __ ]
or uh actually it's cute up here so
you're gonna hear
what she's talking about because you're
gonna hear them you know do a little
dance when i play the screen a moment
but they go on several times one two
three i counted four times
where they reference each other as like
bad [ __ ] or
boss girls and
you know i talked about this earlier in
the week on my social feed and men don't
care about being around women that have
bad attitudes they don't want to be
around
you know miserable women that think that
they're bad [ __ ] i mean
for the most part what i found anyway
and you know i want to hear from you
guys in the comments but
whenever you hear this uh you know this
term boss girl or hashtag
bad badger whatever it is they're
usually disagreeable women with a bad
attitude and they think that they're
something like a dog walking business
makes them you know like a boss girl
you know they walk four dogs a day and
they think that that makes them a boss
girl and they have it all together
men don't want that they don't want
disagreeable you know
terrible women like that um
points high value male read oh
she goes on to tell women that if you
want to be attracting high value men
read the wall street journal read
stoicism
watch documentaries build puzzles
oh um oh and she talks about why men
love [ __ ] apparently there's another
cast which i've i've been told that i
need to look into as well which
is based on a book called why men love
[ __ ]
um and all the hobbies and interests
that that she's covered in
its completeness is really built around
doing puzzles reading a newspaper so
that you're up to
speed on stocks and watching
documentaries and that's what's going to
draw in a high value man now
you notice the title of the youtube
channel is
uh laura rhodes three it's 3g
1k three girls one kitchen so
why are they sitting in a kitchen and
not cooking why are they not showing
you know women how to make a sandwich
it's just them talking about bad [ __ ]
her her her past with prison her past
in porn her giant notch camp which she
suspects guys should look away from so
let me give you the summary because when
i started listening to this
she sounds like a nice pleasant you know
girl off the bat but there's a lot more
to it so here you go listen to this
let me just turn this up some so you can
hear it
oh hang on wrong page there we go that
one
there we go i'm like that's my best
friend
so this this like man
it's throughout the whole thing it's
it's pretty it's pretty gross if i'm
being honest i mean that's just my
perspective you guys
shout out in the comments but we've got
these three girls in the kitchen
doing no cooking no culinary skills are
being presented they're not telling
women to
know any kind of culinary skills they're
just sitting there with their
giant ass mugs of coffee and listen to
the summary now
so all in all a trophy wife is a high
value woman and
and you know keep in mind this is this
is her summary of it it's it's not the
other two chime in
at this point but oh look in the
background they have um
aprons here anyway here we go our eyes
she's well-rounded she has hobbies and
interests
she she works on bettering herself every
single day whether it's physically
mentally educating herself
i feel like the motor is running but
nobody's behind the wheel when she's
talking here like
okay let me carry on finish it found
herself with good people
she dresses for herself not for other
people
and she just loves herself and puts all
her energy in she loves herself she puts
all of her energy she dresses nice blah
blah blah
it's like none of those things show up
on any of the lists that i asked men
to you know dispense when they provided
lists of what they thought was
a high value woman effort into building
herself
and then when she loves herself so much
she'll be ready to go and find someone
else to love
yeah and she'll love that man and be a
great great woman to herself and to that
man
yeah and she becomes surprised yeah and
she's surprised because of all that
because she's done some puzzles
uh watched a few documentaries and and
reads the wall street street journal
i mean the like you know when
when we talk about solipsism here and
how women are are
innately solipsistic and they can't see
past their own noses
they don't know what men want they think
they know what they want
all they do is they paint this picture
about you know just do a few puzzles and
watch some documentaries and read the
wall street journal from time to time
and dress nice and put on some perfume
and
have eyelashes and it's like okay that's
kind of a start
you know like look nice is is good
but let me show you what guys uh say
when i surveyed them so let me pull up
the first one here i'm going to take
this out of the cast
and add another screen in just a second
here let me queue it up
all right share
stop
and share screen there we go
so i just screen captured this
off our rule zero page because i
surveyed uh
the group in there there's a few
thousand guys in there so these were the
top five
a lot of them added extra ones um
and i had to clip those out just because
there was
can i make this bigger so you guys there
we go um
so i just summed it down to the top five
so what they voted on the top one
was respectful and in my frame men want
women that are respectful to the men
and operating in their frame by the way
they don't operate in your frame by
default you have to give them a reason
to operate in your frame you have to be
high value uh you know sort of top shelf
guy that
they're willing to um yield to if you
will
second thing was youth beauty and sex
appeal
the optics of beauty shocking you know
of course that's important now this
one's kind of interesting because this
is
this is a little bit more on the blue
pill side of things when
people say trustworthy and loyal what i
did was and i'll show you the other
survey that i did where people added all
their comments there was like close to a
thousand on there it was it was really a
lot for me to go through
and i took the ones that popped up the
most so trustworthy loyal popped up a
lot
from guys in the comments section of the
community tab
where they're saying i want a
trustworthy and loyal girl
assuming you know that they've probably
been you know maybe the trust was
betrayed in the past and they got
cheated on or they got dumped for some
other dude
but the thing that you always have to
remember as a guy is her presence in
your life is never permanent
it's it's you know um what did chris
rock say in a stand-up
tambourine uh women children and dogs
are always loved unconditionally and men
are only loved under the condition that
they provide something
women are only going to be trustworthy
and loyal to you most you know for the
most part anyway will only be
trustworthy and loyal so long as you add
value to their lives
um you put yourself in a position where
you're no longer employable
um you know thing think you know
circumstances change
in that relationship don't be surprised
if she bounces on you so
don't ever lean on you know trustworthy
and loyalty being a
feature that you're gonna look for in
women they're only as loyal as their
options so if you're the best option
you got them you know the days that she
wakes up back to back
you know weeks and months in a row where
she no longer sees you as a
you know as the best option and maybe
kevin in sales becomes a better option
don't be surprised if she bounces you
know they're only as loyal and
trustworthy as their options so you want
trustworthy and loyal get a dog
said this before we'll say it again um
next one was submissive and feminine
you know that was number four uh
femininity you know surprise
being a feminine woman which which you
know to their credit they
have the optics of femininity uh but
they do state at the beginning of that
cast that they are all a feminist
which is why you don't hear them say
anything like learn how to make a
sandwich for your guy
you know trophy wife should know how to
make sandwiches you don't hear them say
that
submissive is of course very important
to men they don't want to have
i mean they don't want to come home
after conquering the world
putting a dent in the universe working
on you know their craft
whatever it is that they're doing and
then be
you know brow beaten by some
angry feminazi that's going to like hen
peck them throughout their evening
um they want you know they want an
agreeable pleasant woman to be around
which you know brings me to the next
point you know the fifth one was
pleasant and
agreeable yeah alex says so very true
percent
you